what is a one two or three star hunter
it's easy to assume that the star system
is some sort of ranking within the
hunter Association something that judges
a particular Hunter's overall aptitude
in their position or because Hunter
Hunter is a shr manga potentially even
how powerful said Hunter is but actually
it has nothing to do with that there are
Hunters with stars that will blow your
mind because it's all like how how were
they awarded a star and that's mostly
because we can directly compare them to
a whole ton of famous Hunters who are
completely star nud for example gong
Kila Leorio and kopa they're expected
all still very much rookies in the grand
scheme of things but what if I told you
that kite wasn't even a single star
hunter in fact let's go way further half
of the zodiacs aren't even starred
Hunters they're considered to be the 12
most powerful and influential figures
within the association and yet half of
them don't even have this honor and to
really give you a sense of how this
works here is the most shocking thing
former chairman Isaac netro himself
didn't even have a single star what I'm
trying to say is that these people are
very special power alone does not Grant
you a star what this honor requires is
far more than a selfish Pursuit what a
hunter needs to do is revolutionize an
aspect of humanity and provide progress
To The World At Large in their selected
field you need to become this world's
equivalent of Edison Tesla Da Vinci or
Logan Paul that's the sort of standard
we're looking for here and that's why
people like Isaac net didn't qualify
because even though he oversaw and
perhaps even instituted the star system
his whole life's Focus was about finding
strong opponents and self-development he
didn't provide that remarkable
breakthrough that the association
theoretically exists for and it's
specifically the hunter bylaws that
state one star is given to a hunter who
produces remarkable achievements in a
particular field so let's meet the
hunters who have managed to do just that
the single star hunter we're most
familiar with is morel minassi and I
think people often forget what kind of
Hunter he is because it's not all that
relevant during the chimeran talk but
moral is a Sea Hunter someone who
specializes in searching the waters for
a mixture of scientific and
archaeological purposes there was that
one time it was relevant where lol
unfortunately tried to fight moral with
a water-based ability to which Marl said
LOL and then proceeded to beat LOL by
sucking up all of the airs and leaving
LOL with death via carbon dioxide
poisoning but Marl was a single star
hunter before the Chimera Anar so I can
only imagine that morl discovered
something of great importance in the
vast Seas of the world that had been
previously unknown to humanity that or
discovered something that was thought to
be lost like whatever the hunt Hunter
equivalent of the Titanic is maybe even
the remnant of a failed Dark Continent
voyage and that's why there's no one
more qualified than him to be leading
the black whale one to the Dark
Continent as we speak pretty important
stuff but the first start Hunter we meet
happens as early as chapter 10 of the
manga it is of course meni who is a
single star Gourmet Hunter and she is
described as follows one of the world's
most prominent chefs and a true Epicure
her dishes reflect Artistry and
sophistication her contributions to
culinary culture have been invaluable
this at the age of only 21 has earned
her the title title of single star
hunter so it's implied that men's
contributions exist in the sphere of
upper class dining I imagine she's
absolutely scow with the available Walt
searching for new ingredients to create
Innovative new flavors that the human
tongue has never had the pleasures of
sampling and we do see an example of
this with the spider eagles egg in the
hunter exam and Menchi isn't just the
first St hunter in the series but also
the youngest of any St Hunters that we
know of there's a couple who could be
around men's age but they go to Great
difficulties to hide their appearance so
it's hard to tell but look men she's not
the strongest however she is very much
the epitome of what it means to be a
hunter taking desire resources and
ability and applying all of that to a
specific area and innovating Humanity
hence why she gets a shiny shiny star
and also sitting at the epitome of
hunted them apparently is cutie Beauty
one of the more wacky hunt hunt
characters and cutie beauty is very much
Togashi predicting Instagram influencers
so cutie beauty is a cute Hunter meaning
that her goal is twofold one is to
maintain and accentuate the beauty of
herself and others but the other is a
much more Grand goal which was as stated
by cutie Beauty herself to make the
world cute she has a vision for the
entire planet and I think it's fair to
assume that her contribution was made
within the realm of beauty and or
anti-aging although one user of the Hun
Hunter subreddit decided to nullify this
progress and removed cutie Beauty's
makeup Botox and even breasts but cutie
Beauty's position was so well respected
admired and SED over that she was a
serious candidate to become the next
Hunter chairman and when she did lose
her concession speech was actually quite
alarming why did I lose but I haven't
lost at all the cute Association I
proposed will become reality through my
respected colleague pariston all my
angels who voted for me please give your
votes to him interesting to note that
she seemed to have formed an alliance
with pariston which likely alludes to
the idea that cutie beauty is anything
but behind the scenes in fact she's
referred to in the manga as Piston's
head groupy so this is like giving money
to an only fans girl just for her to
spend it on another only fans Creator
and look pariston puts on a good show
bet everyone knows he's an actor
especially amongst Hunters of influence
so cutie Beauty knew exactly who he was
and decided to go all in on parist
regardless so she is a single star
hunter to be feared as is xona the
hacker Hunter his specialty is obviously
with computers and the things it is that
people do with computers yane is very
potentially a global Authority on
anything to do with programming a close
second would likely be miliki zic and
one day miliki may even be the global
Authority if he spends less time with
his numerous numerous sex dolls speaking
of miliki is the first person to mention
the existence of hacker Hunters miliki
mentions the potential of hacking the
hunter website but he doesn't want the
hacker hunters and the quote net police
on his back hacker Hunters are implied
to be focused on dealing with cyber
crime so I Shane likely got his Star by
doing something huge like bringing down
the hunt to hunt World equivalent of the
Silk Road it should be noted that Ian P
never speaks he only communicates
through written words and Di Shane is a
self-professed resident of the digital
world apparently in hun Hunter this even
special term for it called a netizen and
despite having no real care for the
world or the association itself Exane
made it all the way through to the fifth
round of voting in the chairman election
making him genuinely one of the most
popular hunters in the entire
Association which is again despite the
fact that he doesn't really want
anything to do with the association or
reality as a whole chane and Jing also
implied to be friends and part of Greed
Island is even modeled after him which
is the spell card shop in madora in fact
it's heavily speculated that ampe was
one of the 11 creators of GRE Island
because each letter in the words Greed
Island represents one of the founders
and whilst we filled out all of greed we
currently only have one confirmed member
of the island section which is list as
the L but the I is almost certainly for
Shon next up says G you might recognize
him as that guy who was on great Island
but I forget why and in case you have
forgotten because most do he is a
jackpot Hunter which is one of the
coolest titles a hunter can have but
what does it mean well let's examine his
introduction says G the jackpot Hunter
he openly admits that all of his hunts
are for financial gain yet his
achievements have earned him single star
status essentially he's a money Hunter
and I just want to take a moment to stop
and explain just how out of this world
his Pursuits are remember that simply
being granted the status of Hunter is
practically a license to print money in
fact the license itself can be used as
collateral to take out a loan of 100
million Jenny from quote any bank it's
at the point where 60 of the world's top
100 richest people are hunters and of
those 60 none that we know of are
jackpot Hunters Hunters so sgara is
after colossal prizes that we can't even
conceive of he's also a very curious
exception to The Standard of St hunters
in this case sgara has been so selfish
that his Pursuits have somehow gone on
to significantly benefit the world which
is why he was hired by Beta to complete
Greed Island and attain quite possibly
the greatest Financial prize that has
ever been offered but unlike most St
Hunters it's almost impossible to gauge
what cesera did to earn his star because
it's a very vague broad niche of hunting
he can essentially go after anything
that results in a nce ton of money which
is actually what the Phantom troop does
as well and aan to imagine how Sara's
own personal acquisition of money led to
the benefit of others but it may have
had to do with moving such a large
quantity of money like we're talking the
size of a national GDP and injecting it
elsewhere and then we have bushida
ambitious Hunter Hunter's rather poor
answer to Emison bushida is a blacklist
Hunter and these are actually the most
common type of Hunter within the
association they specialize in hunting
criminals chasing bounties and generally
pursuing items individual and activities
within the underworld and the most
famous Blacklist Hunter is actually kopa
who was hunting the Scarlet eyes of his
clan but for bushida to have been
awarded a shiny star he must have done
something massive like bring down an
incredibly powerful Mafia family or
recover an artifact of critical
importance from the underworld or be
responsible for taking down a
world-renowned criminal for example if a
hunter were to single-handedly take out
the Phantom troop then they would almost
certainly be awarded a star and despite
how Infamous the Phantom troop are it
would be only one one star that should
give you an idea of just how almost
impossible it is to earn even a single
star let alone two stars and let alone
again three stars but back to bushor he
was a member of the association
disciplinary committee which means that
in the rare circumstance where the
hunter Association has to take action
against other Hunters he's the dude it
is who gets the task bidor was also part
of nro's pure Paladin Squad so in terms
of power this guy must be pretty damn
serious but not quite serious enough
because he was killed off screen by Hoka
the chairman election Arc in the manga
it's actually pretty sad bushida like
bravely sets out and then we essentially
just cut to his death being announced on
television at least in the anime they
showed a bit of his corpse and such but
narratively he turned out to be a bit of
a a bit of a nothing character but what
he wanted to do was specifically revise
the fourth Hunter bylaw which is Hunters
shall not Target other Hunters unless
they commit heinous crimes which is
actually a bit ironic because buid door
was targeted by Hoka another Hunter
despite bushor and not having committed
a heinous crime but also having attained
a single star is sanika Norton who you
may never have heard of but she's a bit
of a cult fan favorite sanika is a virus
Hunter which is even referenced in her
last name Norton almost certainly being
a reference to that thing we all know
and when the big real world virus that I
can't say on YouTube broke out Sika had
a brief tenure as an awareness
Ambassador online encouraging Hunter
Hunter Fans to stay healthy and even
wear masks realistically to earn her
status as a singl star hunter she would
have had to do something along the lines
of developing a vaccine or even even
outright eradicating a virus in the
first round of the chairman election she
was tied for 11th place with cutie
Beauty and they could not be more
different people cutie Beauty focuses
purely on appearance and sanika goes to
Great extent to hide her appearance and
is rarely seen in public she really just
wants to focus and do her own thing
sanika never had any desire to become
chairman but others were keen on her and
while she hasn't had a big role in the
story sanika is going to be integral to
the Dark Continent Expedition because
the hunter Association are walking into
a completely unknown landmass while not
completely unknown there is one thing we
know which is that it's packed with a
lot of things that are antithetical to
the existence of humans including
diseases lots and lots of diseases such
as zai the immortality disease so Sika
has been charged with preparing a
disease counter manual trying to log
predict and counter anything that may
come up to which I say good luck but
that's a taste of what it takes to earn
even a single star but what if I told
you that there were six individuals in
this world who have been awarded a
double star license each Living Legends
in their own right that we're going to
examine in the next video